I can Army's out there I'm gonna get the
pro now think about it when you're on
the moon with the rocket that's going to
take you home
there's several things that are really
important the first thing is that you
want your fuel and the oxidizer to react
you don't want to have to get out of the
rocket and start lighting matches in the
hope that the thing is going to react
you then also want to make sure that
when it reacts it reacts with a lot of
energy her great axle will prepare for
firing by closing the second vessel
retreating to a safe distance
and opening the switch
chemistry from developed here at
Nottingham has a direct connection with
the landing on the moon that we're all
celebrating this weekend we go with a
launch
oh my go so this is a master's thesis
which I just got hold of a few minutes
ago and I think that it contains a
reference to the chemistry that brought
armstrong and aldrin back from the moon
that this dissertation was written by a
student called ray Thompson who was a
student here from the 1940s he began
here I think in 1947 or 48 this type of
chemical reaction of hypergolic chemical
reaction whereas the rocket feel used in
the Apollo program so as you can see one
of our workshop technicians many years
ago is made here at the University of
Nottingham Zone Apollo spacecraft and
essentially there's a rocket motor and a
jet this thesis is about the reactions
of a molecule n2o4 two nitrogen atoms
four oxygen atoms joined by very long
bond now we need to charge both our fuel
and our oxidant into the fuel tanks and
the oxygen tanks before we start our
chemical reaction n2o4 is quite an
unusual molecule it's a rather sort of
colorless liquid slightly green or brant
greenish Brown so first we're going to
put in the oxygen this is the end 204
and the n2o4 is a gas and we're going to
condense it into a cold or a pre cooled
vessel before pouring it into our fuel
tank when it vaporizes it falls in a
part into two pieces no.2 which is dark
which are dark brown gas so you have
this liquid with the dark brown gas
above it you can see the orange liquid
with the vapor above now it's very
volatile it boils at 21 degrees C so we
have to keep it cold
and we put it into the reaction chamber
and the point about it is that it has
very weak bombs which makes it very
reactive because when it reacts it
produces n2 nitrogen and n2 has the
strongest bond between any two atoms
that exists
so when n2o4 reacts it releases a huge
amount of heat so the source of fuel is
the asymmetric dimethyl hydrazine and so
what Rae Thompson discovered I think
almost by chance is a tiny bit of this
report is shown in one of the papers
that he bound in here and he did some
reactions which legend says and I don't
know if it's true ended in quite a
serious explosion and because he writes
in this paper here which was in the
journal Nature which is one of the most
prestigious journals Suton writing he
said both ammonia and diethyl amine
which contains NH bonds react
explosively with it and to fall so we
prepare for firing by closing the second
vessel retreating to a safe distance and
opening the switch
so as you can see upon mixing the two
hypergolic mixtures an instantaneous
exothermic reaction with a rapid amount
of thrust with the small gasses and
vapour rushing from the bottom of the
rocket so a great way to get the Apollo
spacecraft back off the moon without
having to use an external ignition
source which could go wrong I always
feel a warm feeling with every time I
talk about into a fall because I think
of the connection between my colleagues
here and Nottingham and the astronauts
coming safely back from the moon though
I'm not sure when they were sitting in
the lunar module that they knew the
chemistry had originated in an explosion
in Nottingham